>> Tucker: WE CLOSE THE WEEK
WITH LOOKING AT THE INTRODUCTION
OF PERFORMANCE-ENHANCING DRUGS
INTO CAMEL BEAUTY CONTESTS.
HOW DO YOU JUDGE A CAMEL
PAGEANT.
WE HAVE A CAMEL HERDER AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> LOOK, IT'S A BIT OF AN
UNUSUAL STORY, THAT'S FOR SURE,
IT'S BIG MONEY AND BIG PRESTIGE
AND EVERYBODY WANTS TO WIN.
WHATEVER IT TAKES I SUPPOSE.
>> Tucker: YES, I WANT TO BE
CLEAR UP FRONT GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THIS COUNTRY, I'M
NOT OBJECTIFYING CAMELS FOR WHO
THEY ARE NOT JUST HOW THEY LOOK.
HOW DO YOU TELL THE TELL THE
ATTRACTIVE CAMEL.
>> BEAUTY SET THE KNIFE BE
>> BEAUTY SET THE KNIFE B
>> BEAUTY SET THE KNIFE --
>> BEAUTY SET THE KNIFE -- E
>> BEAUTY SET THE KNIFE -- EYE
OF THE WE HOLDER.
THERE'S GUIDELINES.
ONE MAIN THING IS HOW THEIR
BOTTOM LIP DROPS DOWN SO I
IMAGINE THAT'S WHY THE BOTOX IS
BEING PUT TO MAKE THE LIP LOOK
FULLER AND NICER.
IT'S A GROUP OF PEOPLE SAYING
THIS IS THE CRITERION AND THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
IT'S A WAY OF LIFE I SUPPOSE FOR
THEM OVER THERE.
>> Tucker: IS A DROOPY CAMEL LIP
PREFERABLE TO A TAUGHT CAMEL
LIP?
THEY LOOK FOR AND LOOK FOR THE
BIG HUMPS AND THE EARS PRICKED
UP AND EVERYBODY LOOKING HAPPY
BUT THE BIG DROOPY LIP IS GOOD.
MAGNIFICENT AND HAS THE BIGGEST,
DROOPIEST LIP ON THE PLANET.
>> Tucker: CAN CAMELS SENSE WHEN
YOU'RE LOOK AT THEIR HUMPS --
>> SORRY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THEIR
HUMPS?
>> Tucker: DO THEY FEEL
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'VE NEVER --
>> Tucker: OKAY.
I THINK WE MAY HAVE LOST OUR
CONNECTION TO MR. McCUE WHO WE
SHOULD NOTE IS ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST PREEMINENT EXPERTS
NOT A SMALL THING IN THE SAUDI
KINGDOM WHERE BEAUTY PAGEANTS
CAN YOU DESCRIBE THE BEST LOOK
CAMEL.
>> WE HAVE WILD CAMELS IN
AUSTRALIA.
THEY'RE REMARKABLE AND GREAT
LOOKING ANIMALS.
WE DON'T HAVE BEAUTY COMPETITION
LIKE IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
20,000 WILL SHOW UP.